-Dave and I have a -- We have a
lot of history together.
-We do.
-Not a lot of people know this,
but back in the early '90s,
we used to sing commercial
jingles for different products.
And we had fun.
It was a pretty weird job.
-It was weird.
-It was, yeah.
-What do you mean?
Because of the director?
-Yeah, well,
our director wanted to keep
our performances fresh,
so he wouldn't let us see
the lines
until we were shooting.
We were singing them for the
first time right there on set.
-It was weird.
-Well, I found some of
our old videos,
so here, for the
first time in decades,
are me and Dave's
original commercial jingles.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Ruffles potato chips ♪
♪ They're like corduroy pants ♪
♪ That you put in your mouth ♪
♪♪
-♪ Hensherson's Floors ♪
♪ Hensherson's Floors ♪
♪ Where would we
be without floors? ♪
♪ The correct answer is hell ♪
♪♪
-♪ Yellow sandwich paste ♪
♪ I don't care for mustard ♪
♪ But maybe you will ♪
♪ I just don't really
give a damn ♪
♪ Just kidding ♪
♪ I love
French's mustard...not ♪
♪♪
-♪ Sidetown Discount
Carpet Stores ♪
♪ All the stains
are food stains ♪
♪ We swear no murders were
committed on these carpets ♪
♪ Oh, no, wait,
there was one murder ♪
♪ But it was an accident ♪
R.I.P., Todd McDaniels.
♪♪
-♪ When I say "Franken,"
you say "Stein" ♪
-♪ Franken ♪
-♪ Stein ♪
-♪ Frunken ♪
♪ I didn't say "Franken,"
I said "Frunken " ♪
♪ I win, you lose ♪
♪ Buy Barry's Bananas ♪
♪♪
-♪ Welcome to the
realm of nightmares ♪
♪ Jackals laugh
as you fight to escape ♪
♪ The fires are rising ♪
♪ You try to scream ♪
♪ But all that comes out
is "Lipton's peppermint tea" ♪
♪♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Ooh, bendy, bendy ♪
-♪ Ooh, pointy, pointy ♪
-♪ Arm go bendy ♪
-♪ Arm get pointy ♪
-♪ Elbows number one ♪
♪ Elbows number one ♪
♪ Elbows good ♪
♪ Elbows fun ♪
♪ Elbow high fives ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Can you believe
they found those --
they found those old videos?
-Unbelievable.
-My thanks to Dave Grohl.